Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wie ist das als rasender Reporter vor Ort bei der WM in Russland zu sein? Das fragen wir jetzt Marcus Bark, der freier Journalist ist und gerade im Auftrag der ARD durch Russland reist. Jetzt hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Marcus, schön, dass das geklappt hat. Sein mir sehr herzlich gegrüßt.
Grüß dich, Max. Ja, in der Tat war nicht so einfach. Es musste nicht häufig verschoben werden, aber bislang hat sich das wirklich auch noch nicht so gut ergeben.
Das ist eine sehr schöne Formulierung. Nein, ich habe da ein absolutes Glück gesegnet zu sein, mit einem reichhaltigen Fundus an sehr, sehr netten Menschen. Aber nichtsdestoweniger freut es mich sehr, dass wir zwar jetzt nochmal sprechen können, weil wir haben das Gleiche auch schon mal zur Europameisterschaft 2016 getan. Und ich weiß ja, dass gerade jetzt sowas hier, der Rasenfunk klopft da noch mal an irgendwann. Wir nehmen am Donnerstagabend zu sehr später Stunde schon auf, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das ist dann eher noch mal sowas on top, was eher eine Gefährlichkeit ist, denn deine Tage sind doch eher lang jetzt gerade, oder?
Das bleibt bei solchen Turnieren nicht aus. Das ist klar. Manchmal hat man dadurch dazwischen mal ein bisschen Luft, wo man dann auch mal eine Stunde rausgeht zum Joggen oder so. Das ist natürlich auch so. Aber in der Regel heißt so ein Turnier schon, dass man jeden Tag was zu tun hat. Das kann dann logischerweise auch spät werden, wenn die Spiele sind oder wenn dies oder das ist. Es ist in den letzten Jahren auch immer mehr geworden, auch so ein bisschen zu organisieren, zu koordinieren. Das gilt aber auch für alle, weil Trimedialität wird nicht nur von gesprochen, sondern es ist halt so. Da muss man sich dann auch viel mehr absprechen. Jeder muss wissen oder jeder sollte zumindest wissen, was der andere macht, dann kann man sich da abstimmen. Da geht dann auch ein bisschen Zeit bei drauf. Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass das jetzt unbedingt auch groß anstrengend ist.
Ja, das ist ja dann schön. Ja, das ist schön zu hören. Aber der Körper leidet dann doch ein bisschen. Wie sahen denn jetzt so deine bisherigen Tage aus bisher an diesem, wir sind jetzt am 23. WM-Tag, wenn ich mich gerade nicht täusche?
Ja, das Problem ist, es ist jetzt wirklich eine lange Strecke geworden, weil ich bin am 23. Mai ins Trainingslager geflogen. Und das ging ja 16 Tage, das war außergewöhnlich lang.
Aber im Trainingslager legt man ja die Basis. Ist das nicht bei euch, Reportern, auch so?
Da legt man auf jeden Fall die Basis. Das war auch ganz okay. Das war ganz nett da in Südtirol. Da konnte man auch einiges machen. Obwohl ich auch da schon gesagt habe, also klar, die Bedingungen waren natürlich für den DFB auch wieder sehr gut. Die haben ein gutes Hotel, die haben guten Rasen und so weiter. Aber das Wetter hätte mir jetzt nicht so gefallen, weil es war sehr oft sehr drückend da. Und es gab ja auch einige Gewitter, das hat man ja dann auch mitgekriegt. So optimal fand ich das jetzt zum Fußballspielen nicht, aber da kannst du natürlich auch nichts machen. Und an den paar Gewittern wird es auch sicherlich nicht gelegen haben. Dann war zwischendurch das Spiel in Leverkusen noch ein paar Tage nach Hause und dann ging es nach Russland. Und die ersten, das waren ja glaube ich noch nicht mal zwei Wochen, 12. Juni sind wir geflogen. Und heute haben, wann war denn das Spiel gegen Südkorea? Also knapp zwei Wochen.
Ja, Wahnsinn, wie lange das schon her ist.
Also gerade mal zwei Wochen war Tutinki und dann war es schon vorbei. Klar muss man alle Eventualitäten einbeziehen. Logischerweise kann es auch sein, dass die deutsche Mannschaft nach der Vorrunde ausscheidet. Aber da kann mir jetzt keiner erzählen, dass er damit gerechnet hat. Auch nach den Testspielen nicht. Weil man glaubt dann schon auch immer, was gesagt wird. Löw hat ja auch eigentlich nach dem Spiel gegen Österreich gesagt. Niemand braucht sich Sorgen machen. Nach dem Spiel gegen Saudi-Arabien wurde dann alles besser. Nach dem Mexikospiel wurde gesagt, es wurde alles besser. Und so weiter und so fort. Und als dann gegen Schweden gewonnen wurde, denke mal, da hat wirklich jetzt keiner mehr so richtig dran geglaubt, dass das gegen Südkorea noch schiefgehen kann. Was vielleicht auch ein Fehler war. Weil, wenn man sich so oft sagt, es wird besser und es wird nichts besser. Also Schweden war ja auch, ich habe es ja auch dann geschrieben, die haben eine gute Halbzeit bei der WM gespielt. Die erste Halbzeit gegen Schweden war ja auch nicht gerade überzeugend. Und dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es nicht klappt, ja dann doch zumindest so hoch, dass man dann Ausscheiden in Betracht ziehen kann.
Also die ersten 20 Minuten vom Schwedenspiel, die fand ich eigentlich sehr stark, aber...
Ja, bis zu dem Fehler von Rüdiger war das auch gut, stimmt. Also kann ich sagen, 13 Minuten war das, glaube ich, plus eine Halbzeit. Also eine knappe gute Stunde hatte Deutschland bei dieser WM.
Und du warst jetzt am Anfang dann ja nur in Vatutinki, das heißt, du hast die deutsche Nationalmannschaft ganz eng begleitet. Genau, wie da die Arbeitsbedingungen waren, haben wir unter anderem ja auch schon mit Peter Ahrens vom Spielgeld über geredet hier im Kurzpass. Geht es dir denn jetzt dann auch so, ich habe auch nach allem, was möglich war, die Pressekonferenzen und so weiter mitverfolgt, das heißt, ich war nicht so nahe dran wie du, aber habe eigentlich alle wichtigen Aussagen, alle Spieler und Verantwortlichen, die man so öffentlich wahrnehmen konnte, mitbekommen. Und jetzt im Nachhinein gibt es so mehrere Zitate, wo ich damals, als sie gesagt wurden, schon so nicht Alarmglocken im Kopf hatte, aber wo ich mich gewundert hatte. Und geht es dir jetzt auch so, dass du im Nachhinein drüber nachdenkst und dir denkst, eigentlich hätte man da schon erkennen können, hier stimmt etwas Grundlegendes nicht oder das läuft hier in eine falsche Richtung. Also als ein Beispiel habe ich immer noch im Ohr wie Marco Reus erzählt hat vor dem Mexikospiel, nein, er würde für die wichtigen Spiele geschont werden. Wo ich mir damals schon dachte, Moment mal, ist das nicht gerade das wichtigste Spiel? Das allererste Gruppenspiel ist doch das, wo man die Richtung zeigt. Mit einem Sieg machst du im Grunde, stellst du schon alles auf K.O.-Runde, das sollte relativ safe sein, aber solltest du da irgendwie verlieren? Ja, das haben wir ja dann erlebt.
Hat mich auch gewundert nach dem Spiel, das zu hören. Vor allen Dingen, dass er das ausgeplaudert hat, dass das im Trainingslager in Südtirol schon so besprochen war. Da habe ich dir vollkommen recht. Ein Punkt ist okay, wenn du den zum Start gegen Mexiko holst, aber mit einer Niederlage dann so unter Druck zu beraten. Es ist natürlich nicht so, dass dir ein Startelf-Einsatz von Marco Reus einen Punkt gegen Mexiko garantiert hätte. Aber ich glaube schon, nach all dem, was man in der Vorbereitung gesehen hat, und das bezieht sich vor allen Dingen auf die Vorbereitung Spiele, weil auch wenn man 16 Tage mit der Nationalmannschaft im Trainingslager war, konntest du auch hinterher nicht seriös beurteilen, wer wie in Form ist, weil dazu haben wir einfach, in den 15 Minuten, die wir meistens zugucken durften, da siehst du, wie die sich warm machen, dann machen die ein paar Passübungen, also wirklich Basisarbeit, da siehst du gar nichts. Da siehst du nicht, was die vorhaben, da siehst du nicht, was sie vom Gegner erwarten, gar nichts. Du bist komplett darauf angewiesen, denen zu glauben, was die bei Pressekonferenz sagen und dann mal so die Zwischentöne zu hören in Gesprächen, die man noch so nebendran führt. Aber da dann zu sagen oder seriös zu beurteilen, ist der Antonio Rüdiger oder der Niklas Süle jetzt gerade besser in Form? Das ist schlicht unmöglich.
Wie hat sich das dann verändert? Wie viele Turniere hast du denn schon mitgemacht als Journalistischer Begleiter der Nationalen?
Rein bei der deutschen Mannschaft war ich bei der EM 2012 das erste Mal. Das ist schwierig zu vergleichen. Da sah der DFB auch noch ein bisschen anders aus. Da gab es noch die Pressekonferenzen mit Harald Stenger. Danach gab es auch einen personellen Wechsel. So etwas zieht natürlich auch immer Änderungen nach sich. Ich glaube, wenn man das jetzt wirklich pauschal sagen will, schotten sie sich immer mehr ab. Aber man müsste dann wirklich auch im Detail nochmal gucken. Wenn man dann für die ARD da ist, gibt es natürlich schon, aufgrund dessen, dass ARD und ZDF Rechteinhaber sind, haben sie logischerweise dann auch mehr Rechte. Da kommt dann auch der Bundestrainer nochmal zum Gespräch vorbei. Man hat das Gespräch zwar exklusiv, aber es wird ja in heutiger Zeit auch dann sofort alles über Twitter verbreitet oder wird das Video online gestellt. Das ist jetzt in dem Sinne natürlich schön, das zu haben, aber jetzt nicht so, dass du irgendwie was im Petto hast und mehr Informationen als andere. Wie das bei den Zeitungen jetzt war, was die an Einzelgesprächen gekriegt haben in Watutinggi, das weiß ich gar nicht mehr so genau. In Südtirol weiß ich wohl, dass es ein Grummen gab, weil das auch zurückgefahren wurde. Dann gab es natürlich den Medientag, da kann man auch eine Zeit lang von zehren. Da hat man ja wirklich die Chance, mit jedem zu sprechen, wenn auch nicht so lange und natürlich auch nie alleine. Es sei denn, man wählt wirklich Spiele aus, wo man weiß... Das sind sehr große Spiele. Genau. Also so ein Jonas Hektor oder so ein Marvin Plattenhard, Matthias Ginter oder so. Die sitzen dann auch durchaus mal alleine da. Dann hat man wirklich die Chance, mit denen was zu besprechen, was andere da nicht mitkriegen. Aber das ist ja auch nicht so, dass da irgendwas bei rauskommt, wo alle denken, boah, das ist ein Hammer. Und ja, die Pressekonferenzen hat man dann gehabt. Aber ich habe auch, als wir dann da abgehauen sind, noch zum Kollegen gesagt, ich sage, waren das jetzt fünf oder sechs hier? Wir waren gar nicht häufig in dem Kinosaal. Dann gab es die eine mit Manuel Neuer, die hatte sich so verspätet, dass wir dann schon abhauen mussten, weil das war an dem Tag, als es nach Kazan ging.
Aber setzt du dich jetzt noch im Nachhinein mit eurer und deiner Berichterstattung über die Nationalmannschaft auseinander? Also ich denke immer noch sehr viel drüber nach, wie ich im Rasenfunk drüber gesprochen habe. Ich bin da zum Teil auch kritisiert worden, vor allem für die Folge nach dem direkten Ausscheiden. Da wurden fehlende Beißhemmungen unterstellt. Also da waren wir zu wenig Gerantik. Und ich denke da sehr viel drüber nach, hätte man da kritischer sein müssen. Auch Jens Weinreich hat da unter anderem ein Tweet abgesetzt, wo er gesagt hat, wie kann denn das sein, dass das alle Journalisten nicht gesehen haben. Und ich finde, dass es, also es ist keine Frage, die mit Schwarz oder Weiß zu beantworten ist, sondern da muss man schon ins Detail gehen. Aber beschäftigst du dich da jetzt auch während des laufenden Turniers auch immer noch damit oder hast du dafür gar keine Zeit?
Nee, habe ich tatsächlich, als ich das vom Jens gelesen habe, auch gemacht. Da hatte ich mir dann auch noch mal einen Text angeguckt. Ich weiß auch ganz genau, das war nach dem Saudi-Arabienspiel, da hatte ich einen Text geschrieben, der war getitelt mit Problemen auf zwei Ebenen. Die eine Ebene waren die Pfiffe gegen Gündogan und die anderen waren die sportlichen. Und ich will nicht sagen, dass man nicht vielleicht zu unkritisch war, aber letztlich ist es ja auch die Aufgabe von Beobachtern, zu sagen, was sie beobachtet haben und diese Probleme zu beschreiben. Und dass man dann jetzt explizit den Satz darunter schreiben muss, wenn das so weitergeht, dann könnte es aber auch in der Vorrunde einen Ausscheiden geben. Da habe ich mir dann auch gedacht, ja, das ist so letztlich, wie wenn jemand sagt, es kann sein, dass die gewinnen, so bei einer Tipprunde, kann aber auch sein, dass es unentschieden, oder vielleicht gewinnt sogar auswärts. Das bringt dann dann noch irgendwie nicht weiter. Dass man, so wenn man den Leuten dann glaubt, und du musst es ja letztlich auch transportieren, wenn der Löw, wie nach dem Spiel gegen Österreich, hat er ja schon klar die Fehler benannt. Der hat die Mannschaft recht hart kritisiert. Man muss ja auch immer mitbeachten, was wird gerade nicht gesagt. Man muss die Zwischentöne bei dem hören, was gesagt wird. Man muss auch immer beachten, was wird gerade nicht gesagt. Und das war schon recht heftige Kritik nach dem Österreich-Spiel. Das ist auch, glaube ich, bei vielen so durchgekommen. So dass er dann aber auch irgendwie zum Schluss sagt, das wird zum Turnierstart hin besser, ist natürlich einmal logisch, weil du solltest ja bei optimalem Verlauf deine Mannschaft schon so trainieren und die Belastung oder das Training so steuern, dass du tatsächlich dann zum Turnier topfit bist. Und das war jetzt zwei Wochen vor Abreise, glaube ich. Ne, zwei Wochen vor dem ersten Spiel. Und da glaubt man das dann auch noch. Aber ich glaube, die Probleme, die es da gibt sportlich, die wurden benannt. Ob jetzt angemessen benannt und in der Schärfe benannt, kann man im Nachhinein nicht beurteilen, was sicherlich ein bisschen unter den Tisch gefallen ist und vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr abgebügelt wurde, war diese Quartierswahl. Ich hab jetzt eben noch mal in die Agenturen geguckt. Ich hab's sogar noch hier. Letztlich ist das natürlich klar, dass ein Quartier nicht darüber entscheidet, ob man die Vorrunde übersteht oder nicht. Das ist ja logisch.
Aber es war so eine grundsätzliche Entscheidung.
Genau, es war eine grundsätzliche Entscheidung. Das ist ja ein komplett offenes Geheimnis. Das gibt es erst nicht seit den Bildern von Joachim Löw, wie er an einer Laterne lehnt, dass Löw lieber nach Sochi gegangen wäre. Das hatte er zumindest zwischen den Zeilen gesagt. Das war ein offenes Geheimnis. Wenn du eine Strecke von fünf Wochen hoffst zu haben, spielt das Quartier natürlich eine Rolle. Dieses Quartier in Watutinki war nun gar nicht DFB-like. Das war auch nicht Jogi Löw-like. Da hätte man vielleicht schon mal zumindest die Frage stellen können, was ist jetzt da zwischen Bierhoff und Löw passiert. Bierhoff hat es ja so verkauft, als sei das besser. Auch mit Blick auf den weiteren Verlauf des Turniers. Und deshalb hat mich jetzt gerade das Zitat, was ich jetzt immer noch nicht gefunden habe, müsste ich aber eigentlich gleich wieder... Ich fand es nämlich wirklich sehr bemerkenswert. Da ist es. Also es geht um das Interview in der Welt, was dann morgen erscheinen müsste, denke ich mal. Wer glaubt, dass der Schuss von Julian Brand am Pfosten nun nicht im Tor gelandet ist, weil wir in einem Vier-Sterne-Plus-Hotel gewohnt oder unser Bus dunkle Scheiben hat, der setzt die falschen Prioritäten. Das hört sich natürlich ganz gut an, ist ja auch vollkommen richtig, habe ich ja eben gesagt. Du gewinnst mit einem Quartier kein Spiel. Nur bei falschen Prioritäten frage ich mich ja dann, wenn man die Prioritäten so setzt, dass es wichtig ist, im Viertel, Halb- und Finale keine längeren Flugreisen mehr zu haben, wer setzt denn dann die falschen Prioritäten? Das hatte ich auch, glaube ich, irgendwann mal geschrieben. In einer Sportart, wo immer gesagt wird, wir denken von Spiel zu Spiel, das fährt von hinten auf zu zäumen und zu sagen, wir müssen aber hinterher näher an Moskau sein. Und das ist auch kein Geheimnis, das habe ich schon lange gesagt. Ich kannte Sochi vom Konfett-Cup. Der ganz große Vorteil daran ist auch, dass du eine Viertelstunde zum Flughafen fährst von dem Quartier. Da hast du keinen Verkehr, da hast du keinen Stau. Das ist mit Moskau überhaupt nicht zu vergleichen. Und wenn man sich mal den Korridor anguckt, in dem WM gespielt wird hier in Russland, der ist vergleichsweise schmal. Das ist von den Entfernungen her nicht weiter, vielleicht sogar näher als Brasilien. Weil Russland ist natürlich viel, viel größer. Aber wenn man sich den Korridor anguckt, in dem die Spielorte sind, dann hätte das netto gar nicht viel ausgemacht. Wenn du Busfahrt und Flug jetzt zusammennimmst. Und deshalb habe ich das von vorneherein nicht verstanden, warum man das nicht macht, wenn man weiß, dass es einem da unten in Sochi viel besser gefällt. Klar gab es da das Problem mit einem Trainingsplatz. Ich glaube nicht, dass das Problem war, dass man keinen gefunden hat. Denn es muss ja zumindest zwei geben. Denn die Brasilianer und die Polen haben ja ihr Quartier in Sochi aufgezogen.
Also bei Oliver Bierhoff gesagt hat, die FIFA hätte keinen Platz gehabt für Deutschland.
Ja, das kann ja nicht sein, weil sonst wären ja keine offizielle Quartiere angeboten worden. Also dann kann natürlich sein, dass die Brasilianer früher waren. Gut, dann ist das so, dann kann man das nicht ändern. Aber es müssen ja mindestens zwei Quartiere angeboten worden sein von der FIFA. Mir ist zumindest nicht bekannt, dass Polen oder Brasilien in ein Quartier gezogen sind, dass nicht von der FIFA, wie soll man das nennen, autorisiert ist. Das war ja beispielsweise in Brasilien im Campo Bahia der Fall. Das war kein offizielles FIFA-Quartier, sondern wurde vom DFB gebaut. Das ist hier im Verband freigestellt, kann man machen. Hätten sie natürlich in Sochi auch machen können. Klar, dann hätte man in ein Hotel ziehen können oder man hätte da komplett alles gebaut. Hätte man natürlich auch ein Grundstück kaufen müssen, wo man den Platz baut, ist natürlich mit enormen Kosten verbunden.
Ja, aber schon irgendwie lustig, dass man jetzt sagt, Quartier ist ja nicht so wichtig. Aber bei der WM 2014 hat man da richtig Geld in die Hand genommen, um ein nicht so wichtiges Quartier dann hinzubauen. Unter ja auch gar nicht so unzweifelhaften Umständen. Also da haben jetzt auch nicht alle in diesem Dorf hier gejubelt, dass da ein Teil des Waldes abgeheuzt wurde.
Absolut richtig, ja. Wenn ich dich da verbessern darf, Campo Bahia. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum es Campo Bahia ist. Ich glaube, der Bundesstaat hieß Bahia.
Der Ort hieß anders.
Santo André hieß er.
Ach ja, richtig.
Und wenn man sich das anguckt, so schön das ja auch war, aber wenn man jetzt argumentiert, wir wollen kurze Wege haben, Santo André hieß in den Bus, auf die Fähre, von der Fähre. Ich glaube, wir haben die Poller, die auf der Straße waren, und das waren jetzt keine Teller, die wir aus Deutschland kennen, sondern so richtige Poller. Da rüttelte es dann mal durch. Ich glaube, es waren über 30 zum Flughafen in Porto Seguro. Und dann von da aus über São Paulo oder Rio de Janeiro. Gut, da sind die dann wahrscheinlich Scharta und direkt geflogen. Aber da konnte man nun wirklich nicht sagen, das ist logistisch ein Vorteil, wenn man in Santo André ist. Das Campo war natürlich eine glatte Eins, logischerweise, wenn man sich das selber baut, direkt am Meer, immer feinstes Wetter. Aber das, was man jetzt dachte, in Moskau zu haben, kurze Wege, um dann zum Turnierschluss hin Kräfte zu sparen und weniger zu reisen, das war in Brasilien nun überhaupt nicht der Fall. Da passt einiges nicht zusammen. Aber, wie jetzt schon zum zweiten oder dritten Mal gesagt, das ist einer der Gründe, aber ich glaube nicht, der Hauptgrund dafür, dass sie jetzt in der Vorrunde ausgeschieden sind.
Wir reden jetzt ein bisschen mehr über den DFB, als ich eigentlich gedacht hätte, aber mich interessiert auch einfach deine Meinung dazu. Von außen betrachtet sieht es ein bisschen aus, als würde sich so ein Machtkampf abspielen zwischen Joachim Löw auf der einen Seite und Oliver Bierhoff auf der anderen Seite. Wir wissen schon, in dieser einen Frage waren sie sich nicht einig. Man hört in so manch anderer Frage auch nicht. Und jetzt gibt es eben besagt das Weltinterview, wenn du es jetzt eh schon ansprichst. Und da äußert sich dann Oliver Bierhoff auch unter anderem dazu, dass man Mesut Esil vielleicht auch einfach nicht sportlich hätte berücksichtigen sollen, als Konsequenz aus seinem Verhalten rund um die Erdogan-Affäre. Wo ich jetzt erstmal sagen würde, das ist doch eine Entscheidung, die eigentlich Joachim Löw zu fällen hätte als allererstes. Und zumindest finde ich es sehr merkwürdig, sich jetzt im Nachhinein so öffentlich dazu zu äußern. Kannst du das interpretieren für mich?
Ich hätte jetzt auch nicht gedacht, dass man sich öffentlich in der Richtung noch äußert. Ich hatte tatsächlich gestern ein Telefonat, wo ich gehört habe, dass es tatsächlich diese Überlegung gegeben haben soll. Und dass der Zeitplan im Grunde genommen dagegen gesprochen hat. Wenn man sich das noch einmal rekapituliert, kann das schon gut sein. Der letzte Premier-League-Spieldag war am 13. Mai. Das war der Sonntag. Dann sind die abends dahingejettet. Sowohl Arsenal als auch City hatten Auswärtsspiele. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Özil mit auswärts war. Er war ja verletzt. Dann waren die auf jeden Fall bei diesem Essen. Und am 14. Mai poppte das dann groß auf. Das war ein Riesenthema in Deutschland. Am 15. Mai hat Löw im Fußballmuseum in Dortmund gesessen und den Kader bekannt gegeben. Und wenn da jetzt heute einer sagt, wir waren uns der Tragweite nicht bewusst und so weiter, dann habe ich das, dann akzeptiere ich das vollkommen. Also klar spielt das eine Rolle. Wenn die eine Woche Zeit gehabt hätten und zu überlegen, auch mal mit denen in Ruhe zu sprechen, natürlich wird das auch stimmen, wenn die sagen, wir haben mit ihnen gesprochen und so weiter. Ja, aber wie viel Zeit bleibt denn da? Also eingehend sprechen und auch mal auch recherchieren, was steckt dahinter, mal mit dem sprechen, mal mit dem die Berater dazu hören und so weiter. Das kostet natürlich alles Zeit und du musst ja auch diese Kaderbekanntgabe dann letztlich, auch wenn du die Entscheidung schon gefällt hast, organisieren. Löw muss die Spieler anrufen, die er dann letztlich nominiert. Ich denke schon, dass er es eine Rolle gespielt hat, dieser Zeitfaktor, und kann auch verstehen, dass der Löw die mitgenommen hat. Und ich bin auch nach wie vor der Meinung, das ist die richtige Entscheidung. Wir haben während der WM häufiger diese Podcasts mit dem Bernd Schmelzer vom Fernsehen und dem Martin Röschitzer vom Hörfunk aufgenommen. Da hatte ich in einem auch gesagt, das Thema wird meiner Meinung nach so lange ein Thema bleiben, bis sich sowohl Gündogan als auch Özil nicht zum Thema, sondern konkret zu Erdogan äußern. Das war eigentlich der springende Punkt. Dazu wurde bis heute nichts gesagt. Auch Gündogan hat da nie was zu gesagt, auch wenn er noch so oft erzählt hat. Natürlich hat Gündogan gesprochen, das ist richtig. Aber er hat halt nie was dazu gesagt, wie es sein Verhältnis zu Erdogan, warum es dieses Foto entstanden ist. Und wenn sie dann gesagt hätten, ich zitiere jetzt eigentlich mich aus diesem Podcast, wir stehen dazu, wir haben ihn besucht, wir haben ihm das Trikot gegeben, weil wir ihn auch unterstützen, dann ist das so. Mit der Meinung müssen wir umgehen. In der Demokratie muss man sowas natürlich aushalten, wenn die ihre Meinung darüber haben. Für mich wäre auch das kein Grund gewesen, die beiden Spieler zu Hause zu lassen. Ich glaube, ich brauche nicht zu sagen, wie ich zu Erdogan stehe.
Klar, man würde ja im Grunde ähnliche, meinungsunterdrückende Mechanismen anwenden, die man auch Erdogan sehr gut und sehr leicht vorwerfen kann.
Genau. Und dann hättest du, wenn sie das gesagt hätten, dann hätte es natürlich nochmal einen Aufschrei gegeben. Aber letztlich hätte dann der DFB, und das war natürlich ein Fehler des DFB, dass er die beiden in der Luft hängen lassen hat. Es gab natürlich Äußerungen dazu, die der DFB vielleicht so interpretiert hat, wir stellen uns hinter unsere Spieler. Aber es war ja im Grunde genommen mehr der Wunsch, diese Debatte einfach dadurch zu beenden. Und dass das nicht klappt, das hätte der DFB merken müssen. Das war einfach viel zu naiv.
Und vor allem jetzt ist es ja im Gegenteil so, dass man jetzt im Nachhinein einen von beiden, nämlich Mesut Özil, auch noch so ein bisschen, ja, bei einer erfolglosen Mannschaft sagst du, man verliert als Mannschaft, und man versucht dann nicht mit dem Finger auf jemanden zu zeigen. Und indirekt macht das Oliver Bierhoff mit solchen Aussagen dann doch. Was mich nochmal zurückbringt zu der Ursprungsfrage, es fühlt sich ein bisschen so an als etwas außenstehender Beobachter, als würde es da, als würden Joachim Löw und Oliver Bierhoff nicht mehr bei allen Dingen Hand in Hand gehen. Und diese Meinungsverschiedenheiten, die es vielleicht auch schon länger gibt, treten aber jetzt an vielen Punkten an die Öffentlichkeit. Unter anderem eben in so einem Interview. Interview, wo ich mir denke, dass es aus so vielen Gründen irgendwie komisch platziert, dass ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, dass Joachim Löw damit glücklich ist. Glaubst du auch, dass das so ein Reibungsthema sein könnte? Oder ist das jetzt auch nur so eine vereinfachte Sicht auf die da handelnden Personen, die es uns allen halt irgendwie erklärbarer machen würde, warum da einiges jetzt schiefgelaufen ist?
Ja, ich will nicht sagen, dass das vereinfachend ist. Ich muss auch sagen, ich habe jetzt eben auch nur bruchstückhaft das gelesen. In Gänze sollte man das vielleicht dann vorher auch nochmal gelesen haben. Aber ein Punkt noch, den man dabei immer bedenken muss, ist einfach das Wesen von Joachim Löw. Der sagt nicht nur, dass er sich nur mit dem Fußball beschäftigen möchte, sondern der ist auch von seinem Wesen so. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das übertrieben ist zu sagen, den interessiert alles andere nicht. Aber mal das Thema Marketing. Natürlich kriegt er das mit, dass Oliver Bierhoff seit Jahren dafür kritisiert wird. Aber ich glaube, das ist Joachim Löw jetzt relativ wurscht. Der sagt sich, da muss der Oliver mit klarkommen. Der macht das auch. Und ich sehe zu, dass ich meine sportlichen Dinge regle. Und das muss man dabei immer beachten. Und eines muss man natürlich auch sagen, wäre das Verhältnis so gebrochen, wie man vielleicht aus der einen oder anderen Ecke gehört hat, direkt nach dem Ausscheiden, dann passt es ja nicht zusammen, dass Löw weitermacht. Weil ich gehe mal davon aus, ich habe zumindest nichts anderes gehört. Und ich glaube auch, dass das Projekt DFB Academy viel zu groß ist, als dass man da jetzt Oliver Bierhoff in Frage stellen würde. Ich glaube, das macht beim DFB niemand ernsthaft. Der wird da bleiben. Und das weiß natürlich auch Joachim Löw. Und wenn das Verhältnis wirklich zu einer Person, die so viel zu sagen hat dem DFB, nicht mehr richtig stimmen würde, dann hätte er vielleicht doch aufgehört. Zumindest gäbe es keinen Grund. Andererseits muss man natürlich auch immer bedenken, wenn du 58 Jahre alt bist und hast einen Vertrag unterschrieben, der noch vier weitere Jahre dir ja auch gutes Geld einbringt, dann sagt man auch nicht einfach so, okay, ich habe jetzt keinen Bock mehr. Manchmal ist es halt so, wir suchen immer nach tief liegenden Gründen. Und der Fußball ist auf vielen Ebenen, wie das ganze Leben, sehr einfach. Und man muss häufig auch mal an die ganz einfachen und simplen Dinge denken. Und das sind so Sachen, die dann... Und dann wird immer gesagt, ja klar, alle verdienen im Fußball viel Geld. Das ist natürlich auch so, aber ich sage ja, man muss an die einfachen Dinge denken. Und es ist halt auch wahnsinnig schwierig, genau zu wissen, was da los ist, weil man... Es gibt natürlich Kollegen, die zu dem einen, zu dem anderen, manche auch zu vielen, einen sehr guten Draht haben. Aber alles zu überblicken und Strömungen, die dann von hier und da mal kommen können, das ist nun wirklich sehr schwierig. Und es wird natürlich auch sehr viel gequatscht. Gerüchte verbreiten sich rasend schnell und manchmal ist gar nichts dahinter.
Ja, davon sind auch sehr schnell einige bei mir gelandet, was ich immer auffallend finde, denn ich frage da nie nach. Das heißt, wenn etwas bei mir landet, dann gibt es einen solchen Überschwall an Gerüchten, das auch was bei mir einfach mal so durchschimmert. Und das fand ich auch einigermaßen irritierend, ehrlich gesagt, an mancher Stelle. Glaubst du denn, dass die DFB-Bosse, die ja in einer Telefonkonferenz über die Zukunft von Löw entschieden haben, das hat ja Reinhard Grindel danach erzählt, also seine Präsidiumskollegen, meinst du, einer von denen hat auch mal mit Spielern aus der Mannschaft gesprochen? Können die überhaupt so eine sportliche Bewertung aus der Distanz vornehmen? Die waren doch auch nicht vor Ort. Ich fand das einigermaßen irritierend.
Dieser ganze Zeitablauf war irritierend, weil plötzlich musste dann alles ganz schnell gehen. Und es wurden ja sofort Garantie. Ich meine, die Garantie hat Joachim Löw ja schon am Tag der Kaderbekanntgabe gekriegt. Denn es gab ja überhaupt keinen Grund, den Vertrag zu verlängern. So hat es, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, 2014 war es, glaube ich, dass der Vertrag tatsächlich dann auch nach der WM ausgelaufen wäre. Wenn das jetzt hier so gewesen wäre, dann hättest du natürlich sagen können, ich ersticke da jede Diskussion im Keim und verlängere jetzt vorher. Aber es wäre ja niemand auf die Idee gekommen, jetzt zu fragen, ja sagen Sie mal, der Vertrag mit Joachim Löw läuft nach der EM 2020 aus. Wie sieht es denn da mit einer Verlängerung aus? Das passiert bei zwei Jahren Laufzeit nicht. Deshalb fand ich, das war jetzt ein Signal, was völlig verpufft ist, völlig grundlos. Natürlich wird es irgendeinen Grund gegeben haben. Den kenne ich aber nicht. Kann man auch nur darüber spekulieren. Und der Ablauf dann, also dann meldet Sportbild, dass Löw bleibt und dann sagt der DFB, ja wir konferieren darüber und eine Stunde später wird dann gesagt, Löw bestätigt dem DFB, dass ich bleibe. Das wäre auch eine herrliche Formulierung. Das war dann so Holter die Polter. Und das hat sicherlich auch kein gutes Licht darauf geworfen. Aber jetzt bleibt er halt da. Und dann muss man mal gucken, was er macht. Die tiefgreifende Veränderung hört sich groß an. Aber was soll da tiefgreifend? Also eine tiefgreifende Veränderung, da würde ich ja schon alleine darunter verstehen, dass ein prominenter Kopf ab September nicht mehr da ist. Und wer soll das sein?
Ja, vielleicht Ossitentaler oder so was? Ich fand es interessant.
Den zähle ich jetzt aber nicht in die erste Riege. Der ist jahrelang dabei, das ist richtig, aber ich glaube, der ist jetzt auch 70 Jahre alt. Und das könnte man schon locker wegmoderieren, wenn ein 70-Jähriger dann jetzt aufhört. Es kann auch sein, dass ein Co-Trainer dann plötzlich nicht mehr da ist. Aber reicht das schon für eine tiefgreifende Veränderung?
Das ist eben die Frage.
Da haben wir uns jetzt nichts vor, ob ein Markus Sorg oder ein, ich weiß es nicht, wenn ich jetzt aus der Bundesliga oder aus dem DFB nehmen sollte. Also, ich fand, Günther Klein hat es wie immer sehr gut, ein großes Problem des DFB benannt. Er hat es wie immer in einem Tweet untergebracht. Es gibt halt zu viele Ja-Sager. Joachim Löw und auch Oliver Bierhoff haben in den vergangenen Jahren, glaube ich, nie jemanden an der Seite gehabt, der als korrektiv wirkt. Und das ist immer ein Problem auf lange Sicht gesehen. Wenn du dauernd, weiß ja jeder, wenn es auch privat so ist, wenn du über Jahre immer nur hörst und denkst, du machst alles richtig, dann kannst du noch so oft sagen, wir müssen alles gründlich hinterfragen. Das läuft so nicht. Da ist halt dieser Faktor Zeit. Und wenn man das jetzt bedenkt, die sind seit 2004, machen die das jetzt zusammen, das sind jetzt 14 Jahre. Und da gibt es natürlich Verluste auf allen Ebenen.
Ja, da kann man wirklich gespannt sein, wie das dann alles weitergeht. Das nächste Spiel ja dann im September in der Nations League gegen Frankreich. Und damit wären wir ja auch schon beim heutigen Viertelfinalspiel angekommen. Uruguay gegen Frankreich. Sag mal, Markus, wie viel von den anderen Mannschaften kriegt man denn eigentlich mit?
Ich habe jetzt ja am vergangenen Donnerstag England, Kolumbien sogar live im Stadion gesehen. Russland, Spanien war ich auch da. In der Vorrunde ist es dann doch schon schwierig. Manche Spiele sieht man halt gar nicht, weil man unterwegs auf Reisen ist. Bei manchen sind Abschlusspressekonferenzen oder Training oder so. Und oftmals, wenn man im Büro sitzt und der Fernseher läuft, dann läuft der halt so nebenher und man guckt hin, wenn der Kommentator die Stimme erhebt. Was sehr glücklich war, war der es gleich am 2. oder 3. Tag, Portugal gegen Spanien. Weil da haben wir in einer etwas größeren Gruppe zusammen das Spiel geguckt. Das habe ich 90 Minuten gesehen. Das hat sich gelohnt. Das war natürlich großartig. Bei Argentinien gegen Frankreich hätte ich eigentlich, oder hatte auch den Computer auf dem Schoß, kam aber nicht zur Arbeit, weil das Spiel war so gut, dass ich dann gesagt habe, okay, dann machst du das gleich, wenn das jetzt erst mal zu Ende ist. Ansonsten, gerade Brasilien haben mir, waren eben noch raus, Kollegen vom Hörfunk, der hatte zwei Spiele von denen schon gesehen. Der sagte, die sind bärenstark. Und er glaubt, also wenn er jetzt heute tippen müsste, dann würde er sagen, Brasilien macht es. Und wenn ich so recht überlege, ich glaube, ich habe die noch keine Halbzeit komplett am Stück gesehen. Und deshalb bin ich dann auf Samstag mal gespannt, weil, nee, Quatsch, die spielen ja morgen Abend. Ja, genau, heute Abend. Und wir fliegen noch nach dem Spiel zurück nach Moskau. Aber wenn der Plan so aufgeht, wie das bislang aussieht, dann dürfte ich dieses Spiel dann am Flughafen sehen. Also ein bisschen Daumen drücken, dass Frankreich gegen Uruguay nicht in die Verlängerung geht. Und ich bin gespannt auf Brasilien. Weil, wie gesagt, ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht. Ich habe gehört, die Defensive soll dieses Jahr auch sehr gut stehen. Ich kann die nicht beurteilen.
Bei Brasilien ist so ein bisschen die Frage, erliegen wir jetzt alle den Eindrücken aus der Qualifikation und dem, was wir auch gegen Deutschland unter anderem gesehen haben im Testspiel von Brasilien, da stand die Defensive nämlich sehr gut. Was man jetzt gegen Mexiko gesehen hat, fand ich einigermaßen erstaunlich im Achtelfinale. Denn hätte Mexiko auch nur einen seiner vier oder fünf Konter halbwegs sinnvoll ausgespielt, dann hätte das Spiel ein bisschen anders laufen können. Also ich fand, die defensive Stabilität, die man Brasilien unterstellt hat vor dem Turnier und die man auch schon in den Gruppenspielen zum Teil sehen konnte, aber halt noch gegen eine Kategorie Gegner anderer Güteklasse, die hat man jetzt gegen Mexiko zum ersten Mal nicht so gesehen. Und jetzt kann man da personell argumentieren, also Felipe Luis statt Marcelo hat unter anderem gespielt, das ist ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Wechsel für Brasilien. Man kann aber auch personell argumentieren, Casemiro gesperrt gegen Belgien, wichtigster Mann im defensiven Mittelfeld. Also da bin ich auch wirklich sehr gespannt, ob das, was man da den Brasilianern immer jetzt wohlwollend unterstellt hat, auch durch Fakten unterfüttert, ob das wirklich der Realitätsstand hält, gegen ein wirklich auch sehr gutes Belgien, das sich zwar gegen Japan schwergetan hat, aber was da aus Belgischer sich, glaube ich, mir Hoffnung machen würde, war, dass man sich da selber Steine in den Weg gelegt hat. Also hätte man über das ganze Spiel, über eine Haltung zu diesem Spiel gehabt, so wie nach dem 0 zu 2 Rückstand, dann wäre das eine viel deutlichere Nummer geworden, egal wie gut Japan auch in diesem Spiel tatsächlich war. Aber Belgien hat es da in der ersten Halbzeit ein bisschen, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, sie haben fast deutsche Anwandlungen gezeigt, aber es war schon interessant, dass bei dieser WM selten Spiele von vorne gespielt werden. Also dass eigentlich kein Team bisher bei dieser WM schafft, mit Ausnahme von Marokko gegen den Iran im allerersten Gruppenspiel. Da war es so, die wollten unbedingt in den ersten 20 Minuten Tor machen, haben alles nach vorne geworfen, hatten eine Hülle an Chancen. Der Iran hat es überhaupt nicht hinbekommen, die Kalt zu stellen. Und dann hatten sie aber Pech im Abschluss, es blieb beim 0-0 und hinten raus dann das 0-1 kassiert. Und so hat eigentlich bis vielleicht noch auf Deutschland gegen Schweden in den ersten 20 Minuten, hat kaum eine Mannschaft von vorne weg die Spiele gespielt, sondern die beginnen alle immer sehr abwarten. Und bei ganz vielen WM-Spielen ging erst in der zweiten Halbzeit los. Da bin ich echt gespannt, wie das bei Brasilien gegen Belgien wird. Man würde sich natürlich wünschen, dass es von Anfang an hin und her geht, so wie bei Frankreich, Argentinien oder ähnlichen Partien, die wir gesehen haben. Aber bin mir auch alles andere als sicher, wie defensiv stabil die Brasilianer sind. Und was erwartest du dir von Uruguay gegen Frankreich?
Also Frankreich gegen Argentinien war großartig und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass auch Frankreich gegen Uruguay großartig wird.
Ehrlich?
Ich glaube ja. Natürlich ist Uruguay defensiv richtig stark und da kann man sich die Zähne daran ausbeißen. Ich habe es nicht nachgeprüft, aber ich war eben noch bei der Pressekonferenz und da wurde Taborez gefragt, ob er denn glaube, dass das die Franzosen beeindrucken würde, dass Frankreich noch nie ein Tor gegen Uruguay gibt. Das stimmt, okay. Ich habe es nicht nachgeguckt. Normalerweise sage ich ja immer, mir ist völlig egal, ob ich 1950 irgendwie mal 0 zu 2 gegen jemanden zurückgelegen habe. Aber das könnte schon im Hinterkopf eine Rolle spielen. Und wenn ich dann sehe, wenn so ein Godin da steht, an dem Kopfball kannst du eh vergessen. Und wie man da dann vorbeikommt. Andererseits, wenn ich einen Mbappé in der Mannschaft habe und einen Grießmann, muss man jetzt auch nicht so große Angst haben. Und deshalb glaube ich, klar macht Uruguay, Uruguay will den Ball nicht unbedingt haben, sondern will dann halt umschalten. Das können sie ja auch perfekt. Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass bei dieser WM noch was Besseres kommt, als das 1-0 von Uruguay gegen Portugal. Das war natürlich eine Semplation. Und ich glaube, das wird morgen ein sehr interessantes Spiel. Und vielleicht wird es sogar spektakulär, wenn Uruguay einzeln in Führung geht.
Ja, dann kannst du echt hin und her gehen. Also ich habe jetzt gerade nochmal die Aussage gefactcheckt. Es gab eine Freundschaft für im Jahr 1985. Da hat Frankreich zwei Tore erzielt. Und bei der WM 1966 ein Tor aber verloren. Und bei Olympia 1924. Aber danach eben WM 2002, Freundschaftsspiel 2008, WM 2010. Die WM-Spiele waren jeweils 0 zu 0 Spiele. Freundschaftsspiel 2012 und Freundschaftsspiel 2013. In all diesen Partien hat Frankreich kein einziges Tor erzielt. Und Uruguay hat das letzte Freundschaftsspiel da 2013 1 zu 0 gewonnen. Ansonsten ging alles 0 zu 0 aus. Also durchaus beachtlich.
Das riecht doch nach Spektakl.
Das wollte ich jetzt so direkt nicht sagen, Markus. Wir nehmen ja gerne deine Vorhersage mit. Es wäre ja schön und ausgeschlossen ist es ja überhaupt nicht. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein echt... Ein bisschen habe ich das Gefühl, an diesem Viertelfinale wird sich entscheiden, in welche Richtung diese WM kippt. So als Turnier im Gesamten. Also wie man es dann auch bewerten wird. Setzt sich da jetzt Uruguay durch, dann wird das vielleicht so ein bisschen ein EM-2016-Gefühl werden. Dass man sieht, das Wichtige ist, dass man defensiv stabil steht und lieber ein 1 zu 0 als ein 3 zu 2. Und vielleicht auch nicht immer so ansehnlich. Sollte sich Frankreich hier durchsetzen, dann haben wir, egal in welcher Konstellation, ein sensationelles Halbfinale mit Frankreich, Brasilien oder Belgien. Die wollen alle etwas mit dem Ball anfangen. Das wird richtig gut werden. Oder sollte richtig gut werden. Will mich jetzt auch nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster lehnen. Ja, irgendwie habe ich so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dieses Viertelfinale, das allererste, was wir heute sehen werden, ist so ein bisschen das. Wo wir dann so ein bisschen eine Tendenz ablesen, wie wir dann am Ende auf diese WM zurückschauen. Ob es dann die langweile Defensiv-WM war, oder ob es die mit dann doch interessanten Fußball und einem auf jeden Fall interessanten Finale sein wird, weil wir wissen ja, aus dem anderen Zweig kommen nur interessante Mannschaften, wie man da auch nicht unbedingt erwartet hätte. Ach schön. Wie geht es denn für dich jetzt noch weiter, Marcus, abschließend? Bist du noch bis zum Finale in Russland?
Ja, wie gesagt, wir werden morgen nach dem Spiel sofort wieder nach Moskau fahren. Und da werde ich mir dann Samstag die weiteren Viertelfinalspiele ganz in Ruhe angucken. Wo, weiß ich noch nicht. Aber da gibt es ja genügend Orte. Und dann ist ja ein Halbfinale in Moskau. Und das Finale ist in Moskau. Die beiden anderen Spiele sind in St. Petersburg. Spiele um den dritten Platz brauchen wir nicht darüber zu reden. Das ist einfach nicht existent für keinen. Das will auch keiner. Ich weiß nicht, also bei manchen Sachen lebt man sich ja so als Europäer zu weit aus dem Fenster. Club-WM und so sagt man immer, es ist total uninteressant. Ist für die Südamerikaner gar nicht uninteressant. Aber ich glaube, dieses Spiel um den dritten Platz, das braucht keiner und will keiner. Und das sollte man einfach abschaffen.
Und trotzdem reden wir immer vom WM-Dritten. Das finde ich so interessant. Also ich würde dir da voll zustimmen. Aber in der Retrospektive wird immer wieder gesagt, der WM-Dritte von 2010, der WM-Dritte von 2006. Wo man sich denkt, ja.
Ich denke mal, das hat schlicht und einfach damit zu tun, dass es bei Olympia für den Dritten noch eine Medaille gibt. Dass man das, dass man einfach da Analogien zieht. Und dass das dann sowas wie die Bronze-Medaille ist. Und das hat dann irgendeinen scheinbaren Wert. Wenn morgen den oder wenn den Verlierer in der Halbfinalspiele gesagt würde, komm, wir streichen das, ihr könnt nach Hause, dann würden die alle vielleicht noch eine Party feiern. Und dann aber auch schnell wirklich sehr froh sein, weg zu sein. Kann man nicht vorstellen, dass das irgendjemand da noch loggt. Ob man jetzt Dritter oder Vierter wird. Klar, wenn man auf dem Platz steht, ist ja logisch, dass man gewinnen will. Der Unkehrschluss wäre ja, dass man extra verliert. Aber wenn man dann da verloren hat, dann da wird sich auch keiner drüber ärgern.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Und dann geht es für dich zurück nach dem Finale und dann ist deine WM auch beendet.
Genau, da hatte ich ja geschrieben, vorher noch ein Turnier, dann ist die Saison vorbei. Aber wie ich jetzt letztens den Agenturen entnommen habe, läuft die Champions League ja schon wieder und zwar nicht erst seit gestern, sondern seit minimum zwei Wochen.
Absolut, alle Bundesligisten schon wieder ins Training gestartet, 2. Liga sowieso, 3. Liga-Spielplan heute.
Also es lautet dann gegen 60 München, sowas kriegt man dann auch noch mit.
Und Auswärtsspiel der 60er gegen Unterhaching während der Wiesn.
Ja, und Kevin Großkreutz bei KFC Uerdingen.
Es hört einfach nicht auf, Markus.
Ja, ist aber der Skandal, dass der KFC Uerdingen in das Wiedau-Stadion umziehen muss. Dass jetzt keine Ahnung, wie derzeit heißt und nicht mehr in der Rothenburg spielen darf. Weil da, ich glaube, wegen zu alt, Sicherheit oder irgendwie sowas.
Ja, sowas hatte ich auch im Hinterkopf. Und dann haben wir noch gar nicht darüber gesprochen, dass Milan aus den internationalen Club-Wettbewerben erstmal ausgeschlossen wurde, bis es da vielleicht dann wieder eine Berufung gibt. Wir haben noch gar nicht über Ronaldo zu Juve gesprochen. Das ist ein Hamsterrad, dieser Fußball.
Das habe ich auch morgen tatsächlich gelesen. Ist das substanziell oder ist das ein Gerücht, was irgendwie aus dem Mirror oder aus der Sun kommt?
Nein, ich habe jetzt nicht nachgeguckt, wer der italienische Journalist war, der da zitiert wurde. Aber ich habe dann in zwei Quellen, die ich normalerweise als seriös bezeichnen würde, gelesen, dass es schon sehr weit sein soll, dass sich sowohl Perez als auch die Italiener schon getroffen hätten, dass auch der Trainer Massimo Allegri schon eingeflogen wurde. Der hat seinen Urlaub wohl angeblich früher beendet, um mit dem Präsidenten zu sprechen. Es ist inzwischen zumindest so weit, dass ich schon Christian Bernhard, meinem Serie-A-Experten hier im Rasenfunk, eine Nachricht geschrieben habe und ihm einfach nur gefragt habe, müssen wir da drüber bald sprechen? Wie konkret ist das? Ich habe allerdings noch keine Antwort erhalten.
Es würde mich von daher verwundern, weil die Serie-A, die, finde ich, viel besser ist, als sie gemacht wird. Fußballerisch ist da echt viel Gutes dabei. Aber es ist halt doch nochmal eine andere Liga als Spanien oder England. Von daher würde es mich schon wundern, wobei Juve natürlich ein Riesen-Club ist. Und mit Juve kannst du, was du in den letzten Jahren gezeigt hast, auch die Champions League gewinnen.
Ja, und du darfst, glaube ich, bei der Sache nicht vergessen, der Mann ist auf Bewährung in Spanien.
Und manchmal sind es die einfachen Dinge, die man bedenken muss.
Du kannst dir in diesem Land nicht mehr erlauben, bestimmt hägt er auch, oder eventuell hägt er auch ein Groll gegenüber diesem Land und den Justizbehörden da. Denn gehen wir mal einfach davon aus, dass er sich jetzt nicht jedem kleinsten Faser seines Körpers seiner Schuld bewusst ist. Zumindest hat er sich dementsprechend nicht geäußert vor Gericht, sondern eher im Gegenteil gesagt, sorry, mein Name ist Hase, ich wusste von gar nichts. Also, so was kann da schon mit reinkommen. Und dann haben doch die Juventus-Fans so toll applaudiert nach seinem Fallrückziehertor, worüber er sich jetzt auch mehrfach schon geäußert hat. Es sind die kleinen Dinge, Markus. Unglaublich, wie wir jetzt noch den Schlenker zu Juve gemacht haben. Das wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht. Ich wollte eigentlich damit nur zeigen, dass es wirklich schwierig ist, abzuschalten im Fußballgeschäft. Aber ich wünsche dir, Markus, dass du das trotzdem nach der WM tun kannst. Vielleicht jetzt auch schon dann übermorgen. Und ich wünsche uns allen keine Verlängerung bei Frankreich gegen Uruguay. Und wir alle können dann mit einem Gedanken an dich denken, weil du dann Brasilien gegen Belgien hoffentlich noch sehen kannst.
Obwohl man muss dazu sagen, dass anfangs war ich ja doch erstaunt, dass das Mobilfunknetz doch nicht so gut ist, wie ich es vom vergangenen Jahr in Erinnerung hatte. Inzwischen, finde ich, ist es besser geworden. Das liegt aber, glaube ich, auch an den Anbietern hier. Habe ich zumindest so die Erfahrung gehabt. Und ist sogar möglich, dass man übers Handy auf dem Weg zum Flughafen dann das Spiel Brasilien-Belgien schon guckt. Also von daher, meinetwegen lasse auch Elfmeterschießen machen. Also der Puffer zum Abflug, der geht um halb 12 Uhr Zeit hier. Der ist auf jeden Fall da. Deshalb kann da passieren, nur zwei Stunden Gewitterunterbrechung.
Das wäre schlecht. Okay, gut, dann wissen wir, was wir hoffen müssen. Marcus, vielen Dank, dass du dir trotz all der anderen Aufgaben, die du gerade hast, Zeit genommen hast hier. Jetzt haben wir doch sehr, sehr viel über den DFB gesprochen. Wir haben gar nicht so sehr über deine Arbeit vor Ort. Ich hoffe, es war trotzdem interessant für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen.
Na gut, das ging ja Hand in Hand. Die Arbeit vor Ort war ja bis vor einer Woche fast ausschließlich DFB. Und das ist ja klar, dass man das dann auch immer noch verfolgt, wie es da weitergeht. Und von daher, denke ich, ist der Schwerpunkt auch ganz richtig gesetzt, weil da war ich halt auch tatsächlich dann, also da habe ich auch alles gesehen, wie die gespielt haben, habe alles gehört. Und bei den anderen Spielen war es halt tatsächlich so, dass ich über manche Mannschaften, da habe ich nur gehört, die haben gut gespielt, die haben schlecht gespielt, die haben Pech gehabt. Und ich habe noch nicht mal die Zusammenfassung gesehen.
Ach ja, das ist der eine Vorteil, den man hat, wenn man nicht in Russland vor Ort ist. Hier kann man jedes Spiel dann verfolgen. Marcus, vielen Dank. Die Ed Artus69 auf Twitter folgt ihm da reichlich. Es lohnt sich sehr. Marcus, vielen Dank, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk. Ich wünsche dir noch eine gute Zeit in Russland.
Mir auch.
Bis bald. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke fürs Zuhören. Es gibt heute eventuell noch ein neues Tribünengespräch. All diejenigen unter euch, die das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch noch nicht abonniert haben, tut es. Da wird etwas Neues im Feed landen. Wenn es heute nicht passiert, dann im Verlaufe des Wochenendes. Und dann gibt es im Verlauf des Wochenendes natürlich auch die nächsten Kurzpässe. Wir sprechen auch über die anderen Viertelfinals. Und dann geht es ja schon Richtung Halbfinale. Ich wünsche euch eine gute Zeit, bis bald, ciao!